[Music]
we like to think of romantic feelings as
spontaneous and indescribable things
that come from the heart but it's
actually your brain running a complex
series of calculations within a matter
of seconds that's responsible for
determining attraction doesn't sound
quite as poetic does it but just because
the calculations are happening in your
brain doesn't mean those warm fuzzy
feelings are all in your head in fact
all five of your senses play a role each
able to vote for or veto a budding
attraction the eyes are the first
components in attraction many visual
beauty standards vary between cultures
and eras and signs of youth fertility
and good health such as long lustrous
hair or smooth scar free skin are almost
always in demand because they're
associated with reproductive fitness and
when the eyes spot something they like
our instinct is to move closer so the
other senses can investigate the noses
contribution to romance is more than
noticing perfume or cologne it's able to
pick up on natural chemical signals
known as pheromones these not only
convey important physical or genetic
information about their source but are
able to activate a physiological or
behavioral response in the recipient in
one study a group of women at different
points in their elation cycles were the
same t-shirts for three nights after
male volunteers were randomly assigned
to smell either one of the worn shirts
or a new unworn one saliva samples
showed an increase in testosterone in
those who had smelled a shirt worn by an
ovulating woman such a testosterone
boost may give a man the nudge to pursue
a woman he might not have otherwise
noticed a woman's nose is particularly
attuned to MHC molecules which are used
to fight disease in this case opposites
attract
when a study asked women to smell
t-shirts that have been worn by
different men they preferred the odors
of those whose MHC molecules differed
from theirs this makes sense genes that
result in a greater variety of
immunities may give offspring a major
survival advantage our ears also
determine attraction men prefer females
with high-pitched breathy voices and
why'd formant spacing correlated with
smaller body size while women prefer
low-pitched voices with a narrow formant
spacing that suggests a larger body size
and not surprisingly touch turns out to
be crucial for romance in this
experiment not realizing the study had
begun participants were asked to briefly
hold the coffee either hot or iced later
the participants read a story about a
hypothetical person and were asked to
rate their personality those who had
held the hot cup of coffee perceived the
person in a story as happier more social
more generous and better natured than
those who had held the cup of iced
coffee who rated the person as cold
stoic and unaffectionate if a potential
mate has managed to pass all these tests
there is still one more
the infamous first kiss a rich and
complex exchange of tactile and chemical
cues such as the smell of one's breath
and the taste of their mouth this
magical moment is so critical that a
majority of men and women have reported
losing their attraction to someone after
a bad first kiss
once attraction is confirmed your
bloodstream is flooded with no repin
Efrain activating your fight or flight
system your heart beats faster your cue
pools dilate and your body releases
glucose for additional energy not
because you're in danger but because
your body is telling you that something
important is happening to help you focus
norepinephrine creates a sort of tunnel
vision blocking out surrounding
distractions possibly even warping your
sense of time and enhancing your memory
this might explain why people never
forget their first kiss the idea of so
much of our attraction being influenced
by chemicals and evolutionary biology
may seem cold and scientific rather than
romantic but the next time you see
someone you like try to appreciate how
your entire body is playing matchmaker
to decide if that beautiful stranger is
right for you
[Music]
you